is it too late to go to the bathroom way
too late greetings earthlings i'm brent
rose and today i'm the geekiest kid in
the nerdiest candy store in the universe
because i'm about to try on some
spacesuits somehow they're letting me be
the first person outside the space
program to try these things on and
pressure them up and i am extremely
excited
a moment i always dreamed of space dad
[Music]
so for the past six decades most suits
worn by american astronauts either on a
spacewalk or the surface of the moon
have been made by a small company called
ilc dover
now to be clear for the first artemis
missions nasa chose another company to
provide the spacesuits but ilc dover is
still making prototypes for future
potential missions and private space
flights and that's what we're going to
see today the company makes several
categories of suits there's the lea
suits that's launch entry and abort
which are the softer suits that people
wear when they don't have to leave the
space capsule and then there's the eva
or extra vehicular activity suits these
are effectively self-contained
spaceships with integrated life support
systems that astronauts use for
spacewalks ilc dover's focus has long
been on making suits for the few hundred
highly trained astronauts that we've
sent into the final frontier but now at
the dawn of the age of commercial space
travel they are rethinking their designs
so these suits will work both for our
best and our brightest but also for
total space noobs like me
i feel like i've finally achieved thick
small waist pretty face with a big bang
right just me okay fine
first thing we're gonna have you do is
put on some long underwear and then over
top of that you'll put on the lcbg
liquid cooling garment okay then proceed
with the rest of the dining of the suit
okay you don't need to see this all
right getting into these things starts
pretty much the same way as getting into
anything else with the underwear all
right dan
ready for phase two except these
underoos pack in way more technology
than your typical tighty whities water
will circulate through those tubes
there's an inner liner here that keeps
those as you're moving keeps those tubes
from chafing against your skin so this
is sort of a comfort liner it feels
almost like amphibious or something i
mean it already feels cool to the touch
how do i look you look great yeah
before you get into the upper torso just
like to review real quickly some of the
layers of the suit so the outer layer is
what we call the tmg thermal micro
meteorite garment and then there are
several layers of insulation beneath
that basically the idea is to keep
my body heat reflecting back keep your
body heat reflecting back in then this
is a liner layer then there's a
restraint layer that's a non-stretch
fabric that's yeah you cannot stretch
that and then there's the bladder layer
so this is the layer that maintains the
air pressure so this is what keeps you
alive
that first line of defense of air
pressure in space got it so this thing
inflates essentially right and it can
only inflate as far as this restraint
layer allow it to inflate got it
i don't normally need this much help
putting on my pants but getting into an
eva suit isn't a one-person job these
two guys from ilc dover are helping me
position things so that the joints of
the suit and the joints of my body are
aligned otherwise i won't be able to
bend or move once it's pressurized and
speaking of it's a pretty big deal that
they actually agreed to pressure up the
suit with me in it i had to pass an faa
flight physical for it but pressure is
critically important because while you
can survive around 3 minutes without air
you can only survive up to a minute
without air pressure
thank you
thank you
oh yeah there we go
it's heavy but obviously it wouldn't be
so heavy on the moon actually pretty
mobile
oh god here we go it's like being born
all over again push mom
thank you if this seems clunky to you i
would encourage you to go back and look
at some footage from the apollo missions
those suits had fewer points of
articulation and they couldn't move
naturally at all this new suit might not
be silk pajamas but it's vastly more
flexible even when it's pressured up
which we're about to do in three
two hopefully my head doesn't explode
here we go
this is such a thrill
he's got it up to pressure already oh
wow it feels so different when
pressurized
before
there's enough soft stuff that things
bend kind of everywhere so it's just
like a heavy suit and now it's like
things will really only bend at the
points of articulation i can still do
all the things but i can now tell that
it only moves in certain specific ways i
feel a little bit more mechanical like a
chuck e cheese animatronic
just like you know
and now it's time for some highly
scientific tests i actually can turtle
just a little bit if i get scared or shy
i can just kind of
it's good to have options it's not
actually my first time playing with at
least some components of a spacesuit
back in 2016 i got to go to the johnson
space center and do a bit of astronaut
testing and i was able to try the
previous generation of space gloves in a
vacuum box i remember very clearly how
stiff and unwieldy those felt when
pressurized i was able to manipulate
objects but only with maximum effort by
comparison just from feeling the gloves
before these bend way better than the
last ones do
all right i'll take that
dude
[Music]
yeah is pretty damn amazing so
throughout human history so far evas and
moonwalks have been limited to very
highly trained astronauts but i can see
a day where in the future this kind of
thing actually feels really approachable
like i mean i'm in here zero training
whatsoever i'm actually able to move
okay like obviously they're not letting
me walk
but i feel like i could walk if they
would let me
and it's not just the gloves that have
evolved the shoulders now move more like
your actual shoulders do before if an
astronaut fell down they'd probably need
a hand getting back up even in lunar
gravity but now the upper torso is
flexible enough that they can do
push-ups in it which we made jim do
i believe in you remember your training
this is jim by the way ilc dover's
insurance wouldn't let me take their
very expensive spacesuit off the donning
stand but jim has been well trained so
we were free to ask him to do just about
anything jim i didn't know you had moves
like this is it hot jim is that why
you're dropping it like that
there's a lot more freedom from the
waist down too do you remember how
astronauts had to awkwardly skip and hop
across the surface of the moon with this
suit they'll be able to walk more or
less normally ilc dover nasa and various
aspiring space hotels will all have to
make sure these suits are as idiot proof
and intuitive as possible they'll mean
the difference between life and well
schwarzenegger toward the end of total
recall
despite what some billionaires may
promise it's unlikely that civilians
will be going on spacewalks let alone
moonwalks anytime soon
[Music]
until that day comes space tourists will
be wearing the next generation of launch
entry and abort suits which you might
think of as fancy jumpsuits which can be
pressurized to save your life but only
in an emergency these have evolved too
the most iconic of the launch entry
suits are the bright orange suits now so
called the mesis a lot of people call
them pumpkin suits the suits that were
worn for launch and re-entry in the
space shuttle era so that was kind of
our baseline of we need to improve on
that right this is much lower mass than
that much lighter weight and it's much
more comfortable if you remember back to
those bright orange suits they had a big
neck ring it's like a big globe like a
fishbowl
and the ring that it attaches a big
heavy piece of metal so this is an all
soft design the only hard part is
the bubble itself i see this uses an
airtight zipper so when they don't need
the helmet say they're walking out to
the spacecraft it flips back just like a
hoodie a space honey a space hoodie want
to try on the common helmet yeah let's
try it on the com helmet so
let's see oh yeah wow it's
like some serious sound canceling the
dual mics is that for like hi-fi stereo
or is this like just a redundancy it's a
redundancy thing okay just in case one
of the mic fails got it i do i do uh
slobber when i sing so try not to
slobber on those mics
you don't want to hear me sing in space
either
i have to say it's like it's a very
sleek looking suit it looks sort of
svelte if i may say it's super
impressive now unfortunately tragically
even they didn't have an lea suit in my
size to try on and man i tried but i did
get a glimpse in how these prototypes
are made let's start with the sewing
room so right now we're in our prototype
sewing room in our houston facility this
is where we sew up prototypes of future
generation spacesuits i mean that looks
very ordinary i was definitely expecting
something a little bit more high-tech
looking some sort of you know futuristic
sewing machine this looks about as
brutalist as you can get right well the
interesting thing about spacesuits is
they aren't made in high volume there
haven't been that many people that have
taken spacewalks right have been that
many total astronauts right i mean it
looks like it could be from like the
1960s almost well and i think some of
these machines probably go back to wow
our legacy of the apollo era right just
don't build them like they used to right
[Music]
right now we're in the machine shop of
our prototyping facility so this is
where we make the hard metal and plastic
components that go into a spacesuit and
we have various pieces of equipment here
that you might find in any machine shop
again i'm like kind of struck by the not
spacey-ness of it you know it's like
this is something that like your kind of
gear head uncle might have exactly so
this non-spacey sewing room and your
uncle's garage is where they're putting
together the suit that's going to take
normies like me to space can that be
right are they really ready for someone
like justin timberlake to don an eva
suit on the surface of the moon
with the advance of uh more commercial
space flight happening now how do you
ensure their safety when these are not
trained pilots when these are you know
the rankest of rank amateurs right
people like me a lot of it is procedural
when you're talking about the suit
itself the disconnects or things that
would be you know life critical have
some type of a secondary on them so you
can't just take off a glove without
multiple motions got it the equivalent
of like a child lock on the rear seats
yes it has to be very deliberate yeah
good we do have touch screen compatible
gloves now a big driver for the
commercial market people need to be able
to take their selfies and as well as
right swipe and left swipe in space yeah
as these suits become more and more
commercially available your spouse or
niece or nephew or kid they were going
to go into space would you be like yeah
all right i i trust this thing with with
their lives having uh four aspiring
astronaut children i have no doubt that
i would love to see them in my suit in
space i don't know
[Music]
let's hit the highs and lows lows last
minute panic thoughts about bathroom
when you've already got a very heavy
space suit on another low being mounted
to the wall like taxidermy is a little
bit demoralizing and somewhat
humiliating even though i understood
that it was for my own safety sake and
so i didn't damage what is essentially a
spacecraft while we've already got
civilians flying in lea suits and
they'll continue to do so it's going to
be a long time before we get
average people in a suit like this
walking on the surface of the moon or
the surface of mars the suit might be
ready pretty soon but the space industry
just isn't there yet and even if it was
you wouldn't be able to afford it trust
me highs spacesuits have evolved so much
this eva suit has so many more points of
articulation and is so much more
flexible that even a rank amateur such
as myself was able to move around with
relative ease and that really bodes well
for the future of space travel in one
final high
this was just a thrill of a lifetime
ten-year-old brent used to dream of
putting on a spacesuit and floating
around in space and yeah i wasn't in
zero g today but feeling those those
joints articulate around my body and
feeling that cooling water circulating
keeping me from overheating it was just
so unbelievably thrilling i i could not
pry the grin off my face with a crowbar
yeah yeah
he's staying alive in that suit